[Musik]
ich begrüße sie ganz herzlich aus dem
haus der religionen in bern zu einer
weiteren ausgabe unserer streitfragen
heute zum thema für alle
gleichgeschlechtliche paare sollen in
der schweiz bald heiraten dürften so
will es die rechtskommission des
nationalrates
wie aber beurteilen christliche
gemeinschaften und kirchen de für alle
[Musik]
der schönste tag im leben soll sie sein
die hochzeit die verbindung von mann und
frau vor gott und seit 1875 auch vor dem
gesetz
doch die fortschreitende säkularisierung
macht vor dem altar nicht halt in den
letzten zehn jahren ging in die
kirchlichen trauungen in der schweiz
ungefähr um einen drittel zurück dennoch
heiraten noch immer viele paare in der
kirche heterosexuelle paare
homosexuelle können ihre partnerschaft
eintragen lassen heiraten können sie
nicht das bedeutet wenn ein
heterosexuelles paar heiratet können sie
die beiden vermögen zusammen liegen als
gütegemeinschaft homosexuelle paare
dürfen das nicht
bei einer ehe zwischen mann und frau
kann ein ausländischer partner
erleichtert eingebürgert werden und so
den schweizer pass einfacher bekommen
bei einem gleichgeschlechtlichen paar
geht das nicht und auch bezüglich
witwenrente ist eine verheiratete
heterosexuelle frau bevorzugt gegenüber
einer in registrierte partnerschaft
lebenden lesbischen frau im todesfall
der partnerin bekommt sie im unterschied
zur verheirateten frau nur eine
witwenrente wenn sie minderjährige
kinder hat sonst nicht
gleichgeschlechtliche paare können also
in der schweiz noch nicht heiraten
im unterschied zu vielen europäischen
ländern doch nun liegt ein
gesetzesentwurf vor
die große mehrheit der rechtskommission
des nationalrats hat ihn just am
valentinstag in die vernehmlassung
geschickt in christlichen kirchen
herrscht in dieser frage uneinigkeit
soll die ehe für alle auch vor gott
vollzogen werden dürfen wer ist einer
kirchlichen traum oder eines ehe
sakraments würdig und wer nicht und
warum nicht zu unserer diskussion
begrüße ich ganz herzlich hier in der
runde
regula lehmann sie ist diplomierte
familienhelferin leitet den bereich ehe
und familien projekte bei der stiftung
zukunft ch sie ist reformiert und hat
einen freiheitlichen hintergrund eva
cavalli hebamme vom dachverband
regenbogenfamilien gehört zur
evangelisch methodistischen kirche der
schweiz
manfred plog römisch katholischer
theologe professor für pastoraltheologie
an der theologischen hochschule in chur
und sie bevor theologin evangelisch
reformierte pfarrerin in kilchberg
sie will vor segnen sie
gleichgeschlechtliche paare
ich segne gleichgeschlechtliche paare
das ist in der zürcher kirchenordnung
schon seit längerem erlaubt
segnungsfeier nen für
gleichgeschlechtliche paare bedürfnis
und das ist theologischer unsinn nicht
trauung nennen aber eine reformierte
trauung ist nichts anderes als eine
segnungsfeier aber dass es zeigt mit dem
verhältnis von kirche und staat zusammen
der staat entscheidet zu recht wer
zivilrechtlich die ehe schließen darf
und wir was von der kirche her dürfen
nur trauen wer eben zivilrechtlich die
ehe schließen durfte
dh wenn die ehe für alle kommt kommt
auch zumindest für die reformierten
kirchen mit größter wahrscheinlichkeit
und auch in meiner hoffnung die trauben
für alle also das kennen ja viele die
kirchlich geheiratet haben wir es kommt
die zivile trauung dann die kirche
besetzt erklärt aber sie sagen segnung
und traum ist für sie dann gerade das
gleiche da theologisch gesehen
reformiert theologisch gesehen ist das
dasselbe genau grimm manfred plog
katholischer theologe die katholische
kirche gilt ja als bewahrerin
schlechthin de vom eben mann und frau
sind sich die katholikinnen und
katholiken
eigentlicher heimisch ich habe man muss
sehen kirche ist ja nicht nur das
kirchliche lehre und leitungsamt sondern
zunächst mal die gemeinschaft der
gläubigen die auch ihre eigene meinung
sich bildet natürlich sind wir da kommen
wir aus einer tradition wo wir den wert
der verbindung von frau und mann sehr
hoch schätzen ist sogar katholisch als
sakrament bezeichnen
das finde ich gut trotzdem bleibt für
mich die frage ob wir nicht die zeichen
der zeit auch wahrnehmen dass menschen
egal welcher sexuellen orientierung
genauso diesen schritt gehen können wenn
sich theologisch davon ausgehe dass gott
jeden menschen liebt und daneben auch
mit der jeweiligen sexuellen
orientierung und sie stellen als frage
was sie vom verein
würden also sieht man sagen je für alle
nein was ist für sie denn das wichtigste
argument die ehe ist etwas gewachsenes
ein wichtiges argument ist für mich die
schöpfungslehre die schöpfung theologie
kann sicher aber auch dass ich etwas ist
was länder kultur religionsübergreifend
auch für die große mehrheit von menschen
mann frau mit dem potenzial auch kinder
zu haben bedeutet und von daher finde
ich möchte diesen begriff nicht für alle
öffnen
das sehen sie beim sommers wahlkampagne
warum das sehe ich ganz anders weil
liebe ist liebe also die liebe zu meiner
frau ist die gleiche liebe wie die liebe
von innen frau lehmann zu ihrem mann
da bin ich total überzeugt und unsere
gesetze in der schweiz hinken dem
hinterher
sie bilden meine realität nicht ob ich
durfte so eine segnungsfeier erleben mit
meiner frau vor 16 jahren
und das war wirklich der schönste tag im
leben von mir aber ich würde sehr gerne
auch ein drittes mal heiraten dürfen
weil wir waren zuerst im kanton zürich
und dann in der schweiz und würde sehr
gerne ein drittes hochzeitsfest feiern
sie leben mit ihrer partnerin in einer
eingetragenen partnerschaft sie wonach
ihren christlichen glauben leben das war
beim weiter weg dahin
das war er können sie uns davon etwas
erzählen
ich bin in einem reformiert christlichen
haushalt familie aufgewachsen und ich
war lange auch in eine freikirche und
bin da groß geworden und habe das wiso
mitbekommen dass homosexualität ist
sünde und aus ich daneben gemerkt habe
dass ich mich in die sarah verliebt habe
das war ganz schwierig für mich
ich habe lange gekämpft und gebetet und
für mich beten lassen und nach zwei
jahren kam ich zum punkt zu sagen ich
glaube es ist so gott hat mich so
geschaffen und wir versuchen es zusammen
zu leben und ich bin froh dass diese
liebe immer noch anhält
sie waren damals in einer freikirche da
hat das aber dann nicht mehr
funktioniert habe ich das richtig im
grunde genau aber wir mussten diese
freikirche auch zu lassen also das wurde
uns nahegelegt wir haben aber den selber
die entscheidung getroffen dass wir
austreten und und jetzt zum glück haben
wir in zürich in einer methodistischen
kirche eilig wieder heimat gefunden und
sind seit vier jahren mitglied und ganz
also auch so als paar akzeptiert und das
ist gar kein thema also es sind sicher
nicht alle total davon überzeugt dass
wir das so leben aber es ist auch wie es
gar keine diskussion dass wir da
mitglieder sein dürfen und auch zu
unserer beziehung stehen können es geht
ihnen durch den kopf für die dazu gerne
etwas sagen für mich geht es nicht um
die definition von liebe es geht mir
nicht darum die liebe von menschen
qualitativ zu denn das kann man ja gar
nicht
sie können die liebe die ich zu meinem
mann habe nicht beurteilen
und ich sage auch nicht dass die tiefer
ist als ihre liebe jetzt ihre partnerin
es geht nicht darum es geht für mich um
die frage wie definieren wir den begriff
ich glaube das muss man trennen weil man
kann gefühle schlichtweg nicht irgendwie
beurteilen
das war mir wichtig zusammen aber jetzt
doch mal nachgefragt wenn sie sagen ich
bin gegen die ehe für alle wie wäre denn
das für menschen die eben
gleichgeschlechtlich lieben ihren
glauben aber auch leben wollen
in gemeinschaften wo dann ihnen gesagt
wird das geht nicht
das löst eine spannung aus das verstehe
ich wenn wir aber in den bereich des
glaubens gehen die reformation hat uns
diese das neue gebracht dass wir die
bibel lesen dass sie sich selber lesen
dass das volk die bibel liest und für
mich hat diese bibel auch eine hohe
autorität und was ich darin erkenne auch
als persönliche wahrheit das ist ja
immer auch ein persönlicher weg ich
setze auch nicht meine erkenntnis als
absolut aber was ich darin erkenne dem
gehe ich nach das versuche ich nach
bestem wissen und gewissen umzusetzen
auch in meinem leben das ist auch für
mich nicht immer gefährlich die
bergpredigt ist keine gefällige schöne
geschichte das fordert auch mich heraus
aber jedes dass eine überzeugungs frage
und die löst spannung aber ich glaube
aber auch dass diese spannung zu unserem
leben gehört wenn wir die einfach
auflösen dann sind wir auch nicht mehr
ehrlich und mir ist es wichtig in
beziehungen ehrlich zu sein auch mit
meinen kindern jetzt erwachsen sind
da finden wir auch nicht alles immer
toll uns gut dass die machen aber ich
habe diese auseinandersetzung die müssen
wir führen auch aus kirchen und kirchen
definieren dass er dann auch ganz
unterschiedlich auch nach ihrer
erkenntnis die man ich bin sehr dafür
dass wir als christinnen und christen
uns auf die bibel als das grund
dokumente unseres glaubens beziehen
aber da geht es ja gerade darum dass
gott zum beispiel die heiligkeit einer
jeden lebens und beziehungsgeschichte
achtet warum fällt uns schwer in der
bibel auch der hat sich die vorstellung
von ehe von partnerschaft entwickelt und
ich sehe dem ehe begriff nichts genommen
und er wird eher geöffnet wenn auf die
bekommen wir noch zu sprechen aber
würden sie eher sagen ich habe ihnen das
als frage herausgehört
sie haben gesagt in der katholischen
kirche ich kann mich erinnern wie es
eventuell im buch wie ein pfarrer in
bürglen man ein gleichgeschlechtliches
paar zwei fragen gesegnet das gab einen
riesen aufstand er musste danach
zurückrudern
also ich denke er würde heute noch sagen
ich stehe dazu aber der verein sehen
müssen der stand kurz davor seinen job
zu verlieren
also das ist schon realität in der
römisch katholischen kirche würden sie
denn sagen es ist einfach
gewissensentscheidung 1 denn der
einzelnen paare oder wie würden sie
sagen es braucht beides die einzelnen
paare müssen für sich entscheiden was
ist für mich und für uns miteinander
stimmig und das kirchliche lehramt muss
sich weiterentwickeln
also wenn wir nach den zeichen der zeit
fragen dann muss ich an der
weiterentwicklung sehen ehrliches beim
start ist er sagt wir müssen die
wirklichkeit mit abbilden wenn in der
schweiz zehn prozent habe ich gelesen
der menschen homosexuell und lesbisch
sind
dann kann ich nicht daran vorbeigehen
beim start ist es noch relativ einfacher
der muss gucken wie kann ich der
verbindlichkeit wie kann ich die regeln
und auch rechtsrahmen schaffen der den
leuten sicherheit gibt und gerade die
schwächeren stützt
bei den kirchen fällig wäre es in der
hinsicht sogar einfacher dass sie vom
jetzt gehe ich mal von ihrem gedanken
aus vom liebes gebot her sagen das
allerwichtigste ist wie menschen
miteinander umgehen und nicht in welcher
form ich bin als reformierte theologie
natürlich sehr bei ihnen wenn es darum
geht die autorität der biblischen
schriften zu erkennen und hier habe ich
irgendwie meine großen fragezeichen sie
finden in den biblischen schriften keine
einzige stelle die homosexuelle
partnerschaften ablehnt es gibt die
ablehnung von homosexuellen sexualakt es
gibt keine die bibel kennt keine
homosexuellen liebesbeziehungen das ist
nicht das thema und sowieso ist in der
biblischen schriften ist homosexualität
und absolutes randthema in den
evangelium überhaupt kein thema
das wird manchmal media so aufgeblasen
dass man das gefühl hatte die biblischen
schriften seien ein einziges trat
traktat gegen homosexualität das ist
nicht so es gibt keine ablehnung in der
bibel wichtige bemerkung wir haben über
den begriff gesprochen ich habe
versprochen wir kommen darauf zurück
dürfte ich noch kurz klären in der runde
was ist eigentlich mit für alle gemeint
wir sind alle zwei menschen zwei
erwachsene menschen die sich lieben
zwei männer zwei frauen ein mann und
eine frau
es wird niemandem es wird niemandem nur
ein prozent weggenommen wenn die ehe für
alle für alle kommt und ist es doch es
dürfen alle frauen und männer genauso
weiter heiraten
also es sind die bereiche heraus sind
paare gemeint parlamentarische
initiative schließt ja
wohngemeinschaften explizit als oder das
nur noch zur klärung
also ich finde gut die formulierung in
der deutschen gesetzesvorlage die haben
dass er am ersten juli vor zwei jahren
im bundestag verabschiedet und daher ist
es ganz nüchtern die ehe schließen zwei
personen verschiedenen oder gleichen
geschlechts das finde ich angenehm
nüchtern ohne bewertung wichtig ist dass
die beiden für sich in frei hat diese
entscheidung getroffen haben
und dann kommt für mich eher darauf an
wie ist die beziehungsqualität zwischen
menschen und wo können wir da helfen das
zu unterstützen sobald die erste runde
hier der eindruck es ist eben ein
strittiges thema das war auch der grund
dass wir gesagt haben wir wollen erst
einmal hier auf dem podium die
christlichen stimmen zusammen haben und
nicht noch andere religionen dazu nehmen
aber wir sind hier im haus der
religionen und ich geh maria zum
nebentisch im haus der religionen sind
verschiedene nichtchristliche andere
religionsgemeinschaften zu hause gerne
haug sitzt hier sie ist eine der
gründerinnen dieses hauses hier der
religionen sie war auch zehn jahre lang
präsidentin des fördervereines haus der
religionen
ist denn dieses thema hilfe alle wird
das hier im haus diskutiert ja sicher
warum nicht oder
also wir sind acht religionen unter
einem dach aber nicht unter einer
käseglocke oder also das heißt eben wir
sind wirklich teil der gesellschaft und
hier sind die verschiedensten leute und
wir haben auch hier das ganze spektrum
denke ich an einstellungen aber es schon
heißes eisen oder ehe für alle für die
religionen ich denke dass das einfach
ein thema ist es vielleicht auch ein
bisschen eine generationenfrage eine
frage der ersten oder zweiten generation
der einwanderung und so aber es ist klar
dass das spektrum der meinungen da sich
ja ganz weit ist und das ist ja auch das
spannendes einer der gründe warum wir
hier so etwas machen wir verstehen uns
auch als ein bisschen als laboratorium
des friedlichen zusammenlebens und das
heißt dass wir dadurch dass wir auch
unter einem dach leben dass wir eben ins
gespräch kommen aber ganz partner im
allgemeinen ganz pragmatisch auch über
sehr heiße themen auch über ganz
schwierige konflikte also es klingt so
wie auf dem podium ganz unterschiedliche
positionen ja und ich denke kommt dann
noch dazu das ist auch eine erfahrung
die wir macht sie haben jetzt die
christlichen vertreter da dass es eine
weitere erfahrungen die wir machen ist
das eigentlich die interreligiöse
dialoge viel schwieriger sind noch als
die interreligiösen dialog das sind ja
ist er mal das gespräch über die grenzen
der religionsgemeinschaften staat
eigentlich ist eine halb also die
gespräche finden stahl aber es ist
schwieriger innerhalb der gleichen
religion weil die erwartungen natürlich
auch immer auch emotionale ist auch der
muss doch so sein wie ich oder die
musste ich bin gehört zur gleichen
religion neben ihnen sitzt umwelt
mehmeti sind hier im haus der religion
auch im moschee verein engagiert wie ist
es da unter der musliminnen und muslimen
wie wir das thema diskutiert also muss
sagen dass die überwiegende meinung der
muslime ist dass die religiöse mann und
frau vorbehalten ist
was die ziele angeht ist der diskurs
eigentlich fast inexistent also auch
sehr schwach das hat mehrere gründe
ich denke der hauptgrund ist auch dass
die kommunen die haut ist muslimische
community erst in der ersten oder
zweiten generation hier in der schweiz
lebt und die politische partizipation
auch dementsprechend schwach ist und
dementsprechend auch die bereitschaft
über aktuelle politische themen zu
diskutieren weniger stark vorhanden ist
ich denke aber dass aus zwei gründen
dass wir muslime diese diese vorlage
auch unterstützen sollten
erstens es liegt absolut in unserem
interesse
als minderheit in unserer demokratischen
pluralistischen gesellschaft wenn andere
minderheiten jetzt in unserem fall die
homosexuellen bürger mehr rechte
erhalten ihre rechtsstellung verbessert
werden
das ist der erste punkt und der zweite
grund ist eigentlich wenn man sich die
das rechtsinstitut anschaut und die
wichtigsten elemente heraus nimmt
beispielsweise das eingehen einer
lebensgemeinschaft verantwortung
übernehmen für einander soziale
absicherung treue und beistand leisten
das können homosexuelle paare mindestens
genau so gut wie heterosexuelle paare
ich glaube da würde mir auch die meisten
leute wir auch zustimmen ein offenes
wort sind auch der sohn des imams sicht
auf das offenlegen hier in der moschee
von moscheevereinen hast religion gibt
es da zwischen den generationen ein
unterschied dass die jüngeren das
offener sehen
ich denke schon ich denke schon dass die
jüngere generation der offene
gegenübersteht
ja wir haben jetzt gehört eben auch bei
den muslimen muslimen
sie haben es gesagt bei der gemeinschaft
niemals wird die frage für alle
kontrovers diskutiert werden haben sie
auch gehört bereits in der einstiegs-
und auf dem podium bei konservativen
katholikinnen und katholiken ist der
fall klar sie sind gegen die ehe für
alle ich habe vor der sendung den abt
vom kloster maria stein im kanton
solothurn täter von suri getroffen herab
beurteilen sie die ehe für alle
ich denke so eine modeerscheinung und es
ist nicht das wichtigste thema unserer
gesellschaft ich habe meine man den
eindruck es werde von eine sehr aktive
minderheiten mehrheit auch auf gedrückt
was spricht denn aus sicht der römisch
katholischen kirche gegen die eta in der
christlichen tradition er ganz klar als
einen ehebund eine lebensgemeinschaft
von mann und frau der definitionen und
das ist für mich gültig und die kirche
lehrt eigentlich seit anfang an dass die
ehe in der schöpfung begründet liegt
also nicht eine erfindung der kirchen
und die kirche hat während jahrhunderten
die e-modelle der gesellschaft
übernommen
damit die zeit als vertieft auch die
rogge vertieft und dann auch noch eine
die sakramentale dimension hinein
gebracht haben ist ein anderes kapitel
grundsätzlich auch von der
kulturgeschichte honda anthropologie
scheint wir absolut sinnvoll und legitim
zu sein dass ehe ist ein bund zwischen
mann und frau
und wenn jetzt zwei männer oder zwei
fallen zu ihnen kommen
diese sind gläubig wir wollen uns auch
kirchlich trauen was sagen sie dann
dann muss ich sagen das geht nicht also
da schenke ich den leuten wirklich
klaren wein ein und sage ich werde sie
nicht trauen
aber jetzt und wenn sie das akzeptieren
können dann schauen wir weiter
was können wir machen aber es ist mir
gar nicht sympathisch leuten
irgendwelche tricks vorspielt um dann
meint man könne sie irgendwie
hereinholen
das ist nicht meine linie ja peter von
suri sagt eine minderheit ist so etwas
deutlicher will einer mehrheit etwas
diktieren
ich sehe das nicht so das vorzeichen vor
der klammer ist schon ungünstig wenn er
das bewertet als das seine mode
erscheinung
dann denke ich nämlich die menschen
nicht ernst für die das wichtig ist und
ich habe für mich gelernt man muss
unterscheiden ob ich dinge jetzt
theoretisch am schreibtisch verdenken
und da natürlich auch er hat ja von der
entwicklung gesprochen die ist auch
anzuerkennen
aber auch zu gucken wie kann es
weitergehen also ich lerne durch
konkrete begegnungen und ich kann mich
gut erinnern wie ich im jahre 2000 beim
ersten ökumenischen kirchentag in berlin
war und dann sah ich einen stand haruka
homosexuelle und kirche dachte wunderbar
kannst dich mal gleich informieren stand
der schüchtern am tisch und schaut wer
die infos an und plötzlich stehen da
zwei junge sympathische männer mir
gegenüber können wir da helfen
ich war etwas verlegen und kommt mit den
ins gespräch die machen auf mich einen
sehr glaubwürdigen eindruck dass sie
ihre beziehung wichtig wenn das sie als
christen leben wollen und dann habe ich
spontan gedacht ja verbinde ich dass ich
sage geht nicht darf nicht ja und umso
mehr habe ich mich dann gefreut dass 14
jahre später
partsch franziskus bei irgendeinem
rückflug das im flugzeug auch gesagt hat
das heißt die konkrete begegnung mit
menschen verbietet dann einfach schlicht
von modeerscheinung zu reden also ich
schätze ab von syrer das nicht das
problem aber so einfach glaube ich darf
man damit nicht umgehen
also für mich ich möchte zurück zu den
gesellschaftlichen veränderungen
ich glaube wichtig ist da für mich dass
die kirche vom ewigen redet klar die
kirche muss nicht per se sich
gesellschaftlichen veränderungen
anpassen die kirche muss es nicht
geschafft recht machen die kirche hat
den auftrag ist gott recht zu machen die
kirche ist nicht dem zeitgeist
verpflichtet sondern die kirche ist gott
verpflichtet also ich finde die
argumentation dass sich die gesellschaft
verändert egal bei welchem thema jetzt
dass geht mir jetzt gar nicht nur
einfach um die ehe für alle das ist für
mich nicht die kirche zu der ich gehören
möchte die von der gesellschaft von
bewegungen gesteuert wird frau leben
haben ich wir haben als katholiken im
zweiten vatikanischen konzil
ausdrücklich gesagt freude und hoffnung
trauer und angst der menschen müssen
unsere freude und angst und trauer sein
das heißt wenn wir die fragen der
menschen nicht zulassen und die uns zu
eigen machen können wir unmöglich als
anspruch erheben wir wollten anwalt der
menschen sagen das hat nichts mit
zeitgeist zu tun das ist so einfach dass
heißt liegt das nun fragen nicht zuletzt
die frage ist welche antworten gibt man
darauf ich will nur sagen grundsätzlich
glaube ich nicht dass die kirche sich
gesellschaftliche veränderungen anpassen
muss es für sie die kirche das
kirchliche lehramt allein katholische
kirche die reformierte kirche auch die
gläubigen auch ich muss mich nicht ich
bin nicht verpflichtet mich
gesellschaftlichen entwicklungen
anzupassen indem ich zustimme ich nehme
diese entwicklungen war und ich bilde
mir eine meinung und ich habe eine
haltung dazu gut das war das argument
von von sony also sie würden von kirchen
sprechen weil da keine einen halt
herrscht aber ich über spitzes mal sie
würden sagen die 68er hatten die freie
liebe jetzt kommt irgendwie de für alle
die kirche soll nicht jede mode
mitmachen ist es so in die richtung oder
nein ich möchte einfach dabei ich möchte
jetzt das jetzt gar nicht auf diese
modeerscheinung oder so übertragen oder
was jetzt so flapsig sagen sondern
einfach die kirche muss muss ist gott
recht machen das ist das kriterium hier
würde ich gerne einhängen die kirche
muss es gott recht machen die kirchen
müssen dass gott rechnung auf eine etwas
mir noch lieber wäre die christinnen und
christen sondern es versuchen gott recht
zu machen und da habe ich schon meine
frage zeigen
wie man es gott recht machen kann und
dann die grünen das größte geschenk und
für mich die wichtigste aller kräfte die
liebe so zu bewerten das geht für mich
überhaupt nicht auf ich bin überzeugt
dass jede liebe zwischen menschen die
zum wohle der menschen beiträgt ein
geschenk gottes ist den segen gottes
verdient und alles andere ist
qualifizieren da liebe sie haben vorhin
gesagt das tun sie nicht das tun sie
doch indem sie die er für alle ablehnen
und sagen die eine liebe hat einen
institutionellen rahmen verdient indem
sie gewisse rechtliche zusprüche auch
ansprüche aber auch zusprüche hat und
die andere liebe hat das nicht verdient
das ist ein qualifizieren von
beziehungen in dem das sie ganz konkrete
lebensrealitäten schaffen die auf der
einen seite einfacher ist um diese
beziehung zu leben und auf der anderen
seite schwieriger wenn sie daran denken
dass zum beispiel homosexuelle paare
rechtlich einen viel schlechteren schutz
haben aus heterosexuelle paare das kann
doch nicht angehen
also spiele ich wollte hier
die ja über die bibel diskutieren ich
denke jetzt mal dahin
sie haben in einem interview gesagt er
ist gottes erfindung ab sie haben ja
vorhin auch diese ewigen werte
angesprochen können sie das kurz aus
führen also sie werden wahrscheinlich
biblischer argumentieren inwiefern ist
ehe zwischen mann und frau gott dass er
weniger wir können den schöpfungsbericht
liest also ich glaube das liegt zwischen
testament im buch genesis genau und
jesus bezieht sich ja dann auch im neuen
testament wieder darauf bezieht sich auf
das moralische gesetz stellt sich auch
dazu ich glaube diese beiden testamente
die gehören ja auch zusammen und es geht
um die frage ob wir die hebe griff neu
definieren wollen oder nicht skaten für
mich nicht um die frage der
lebensqualität der beziehungsqualität
ich glaube nicht aber dass ein
heterosexuelles paar passe eine bessere
liebe hat überhaupt nicht aber verlieren
sie können doch nicht allen ernstes
hinter dem begriff stehen den der uns in
den biblischen schriften entgegen kommt
also die geräten von biblischen
schriften die in einer komplett
patriarchalen gesellschaft geschrieben
wurden die frau ist der besitz des
mannes die ehe hat nur dazu regal
beigetragen dass die frau von einem haus
stand diesmal es nämlich von dem von
ihrem vater in den anderen ihres mannes
dann ging was die frau dazu meint habe
überhaupt nichts zur sache getan wenn
der mann der frau überdrüssig war hat er
sie haut entlassen aus dem bestand hat
sich oder sonst noch 23 dazu genommen
oder bei seinen 1000 das ist der
biblische betreffen weil wir wirklich
daran christus hat sich sehr klar gegen
die cent lassen zb gestellt und in der
schöpfung steht auch nichts davon dass
man frauen schlecht behandeln soll aber
in der schöpfung steht nichts von ehe in
der schöpfung ersten schöpfungsbericht
steht wie leben entsteht da steht nichts
von mir ehe ist ein
kulturgeschichtlicher begriff dazu recht
da man sich luther zitieren er ist ein
weltlich ding das sollen die
religionsgemeinschaften sowie so
vorsichtig sein zu sagen wie er dann wir
hier schließen darf und wer nicht ich
finde das richtig dass man das dem staat
übergeben hat aber so wie sie das
darstellen in den ähren im ersten
schöpfungsbericht ist nichts von ihm zu
reden
schlägst du es bezieht sich aber ja
darauf christus war da wirklich feminist
als er gesagt hat dies könnte ja nicht
machen
neuere frauen nicht einfach entlassen
deshalb das war auch das was man heute
als konservativ an sieht auch das ist
gegen die scheidung das war ganz wichtig
für die frau dass die einfach nicht aus
dem ehestand entlassen werden konnte
sie haben wohl gemeint der mensch soll
nicht trennen was gott verbunden hat
oder dass man zum schutz der frau das
kann man heute das ist ja dass das
könnten wir auch streitfragen
scheidungen machen
auch das ist heute nicht mehr 12 es
anzuwenden ich bitte doch wirklich an
die an die zeitgeschichtlichen
bedingungen sagt der gute der biblischen
schriften zu denken sonst nehmen wir die
biblischen schriften nicht ernst und
dafür ist im team ihr zu lieb das ja ja
wir haben einen konflikt zwischen einer
wörtlichen auslegung und eine historisch
kritisch nach ich weiß nicht es brauche
ich das von außen menschen die
herankommen an die bibel sagen so steht
sie eröffnen das 1
sie wollten reagieren ich bin über ein
bibelwort gestolpert gestern vorgestern
im galater was paulus geschrieben hat
und das ist mir so hat mich sehr gefreut
dass ist weil paulus sagt da da ist
weder juden noch grieche wieder sklaven
noch noch 3 2 weder mann noch frau
wir sind alle eins in christus und ich
habe wieder nachgedacht das möchte ich
auch noch in dieser runde in dieser
runde sagen weil wir sind eben wir sind
verschiedene meinung aber schlussendlich
und das ist manchmal auch mein traum
dass ich auch als lesbische frau dass
ich in einen gottesdienst gehen kann
da sind einfach alle arten von menschen
in diesem gottesdienst also familien
alleinstehende alle familienformen
grauens menschen alles ist da und wir
konzentrieren uns auf jesus und wir sind
es ist egal weil gott hat uns alle so
geschaffen und er liebt uns darf ich nur
einen einsatz aus dem ersten testament
anfügen und ziehe es war sehr gut die
schöpfung ist gut leben wir endlich so
dass die schöpfung gut es dass jeder
mensch so wie geschaffen ist gut es
ich denke hier beispiel mit dem
galaterbrief nicht mehr sklaven und frei
ist normal ein beleg für das was frau
vorausgesagte man muss biblische texte
in ihrem historischen hintergrund
verstehen denn auch die sklaverei ist
damals nicht abgeschafft worden hat aber
etwas damit zu tun gehabt dass paulus
unter der erwartung des reiches gottes
stand und hat gesagt wenn sowieso das
reich gottes gleich bald beginnt ja dann
brauchen wir nicht große gesellschafts
verordnung noch verändern sondern hat
den sklaven aufgefordert geht wieder
zurück und hat den herren aufgefordert
gut mit dem sklaven was mich
interessiert ist in der intention glaube
ich sind wir gar nicht so
unterschiedlich sie möchten doch den
wert der liebe zu der beziehung der
liebe zwischen zwei menschen schützen
jetzt frage ich mich was ist ihnen jetzt
wichtiger die hülle die form muss die
auch per see gerettet werden egal was da
innerhalb des gefüges passiert oder geht
es nicht darum 1 korinther 13 zu sagen
was sind die qualitätsmerkmale der liebe
die für beziehungsqualität gefördert
werden sollten
und dann ist für mich das beispiel es
wird geöffnet es wird nichts genommen
ich verstehe überhaupt nicht das problem
wenn ich mit meiner lebensform als mit
einer frau verheiratet plusminus
zufrieden bin da gibt es immer auf und
ab
bedroht nicht ob nicht das andere anders
leben sondern was für mich spannend ist
wie gehen wir miteinander in der grund
sehnsucht um nach nahen verlässlichen
dauerhaft und ganzheitlichen beziehung
ich bin mir nicht sicher wer bei mit der
bibel weiterkommen weil ich glaube dass
wir einfach zitieren was uns gefällt
aber wir können es noch mit der
tradition versuchen das hat peter von
suri auch versucht könnten sie uns dazu
etwas sagen ist es nicht so dass die ehe
in der katholischen oder in der
tradition der kirche doch eher zum
schutz von kindern und frauen er von ihr
nicht so sehr auf die bibel zurück geht
lange hat sich die katholische kirche um
er hier überhaupt nicht gekümmert
das muss man auch sehen sondern sie hat
ja also das die ehe als sakrament gibt
es ja es hat im zwölften jahrhundert und
dort wurde zum schutz der frauen zb
eingeführt eine ehe muss öffentlich und
fahrzeugen stattfinden einmal um die
zwangs und zwecken gerade der
adelshäuser einzuschränken und auch die
heimlichen die sogenannten klandestinen
zu verbieten dass da irgendein mann
seiner holden das schönste geschworen
hatte in der dunkelheit und am nächsten
morgen sich nicht mehr erinnern konnte
da ist katholik ist die kirche also muss
ich sagen ist die kirche wirklich als
anwalt der frauen stark hat die sich
stark gemacht hat gesagt wir müssen die
frauen schützen
sie sind die schwächeren und deswegen
öffentlich und fahrzeugen das ist ein
gewinn und dann nochmal auch
ausdrücklich als sakrament übrigens
schon seit dem vierten 401 von
augustinus er hat bewusst dass als
sakrament bezeichnet nur da spielte er
noch so unter dem aspekt zunächst muss
nachkommenschaft gesichert werden und
dann treue und sakrament der das bemühen
nachkommenschaft ist jetzt nicht
speziell kirchlich ist alle ordnungen
wollten sicherstellen
wie wird das weitervererbt und sonst war
selbst habe ich gelesen im katholischen
bayern hat ein bauer erstmal erst dann
geheiratet wenn sicher war dass seine
auserwählte auch nachwuchs bekommen
ja der ist die katholische kirche auch
in ihrer eigenen sexualmoral sehr
zwiespältig von daher sehe als
rechtsinstitut um etwas wichtiges von
zwei menschen zu schützen
ich glaube da können wir uns
verständigen ja die frage ist ob die
öffnung das ganze bedroht oder die durch
das nennen auch anreichert darüber
müssen wir diskutieren ich gerne ein
bisschen über zum beispiel diese
vehemenz zu sagen ja das ist jetzt
ebenso die weltweite kirche sieht das ja
ganz anders es gibt in der weltweiten
kirche wenn wir auch in den kirchen in
asien in den wachsenden kirchen auch
umfragen machen würden dann gibt es
längst nicht diese breite zustimmung zum
beispiel zum öffnung eines begriffs
sagen wir den ja wir haben hier im
westen die wahrheit gepachtet und alle
anderen haben es noch nicht verstanden
ich das finde ich auch nicht richtig da
hat es für mich auch etwas moralisieren
das drinnen solcher kirchen sind ja ich
denke katholische kirche reformen
römisch-katholische freikirchen einfach
wir reden jetzt über und zum beispiel
darüber dass es in der schweiz nur noch
eine kleine minderheit ist die eröffnung
des ebel ist nicht zustimmen will
weltweit gesehen ist das aber ganz
anders und meine frage ist einfach haben
wir hier im westen denn einfach per sehr
echt oder müssten wir nicht auch diesen
kontext einbeziehen
eine gesellschaft haben würden sie auch
wie peter von suri mit der tradition
argumentieren es hat sich bewährt
ich glaube dass die tradition ein
argument ist dass man sich überlegen
soll also dieser respekt vor der
weisheit auch ein traditioneller sie ist
nicht für mich ist es nicht die
tradition die letztlich entscheidend ist
sondern für mich ist es diese erkenntnis
die ich in meiner beziehung zu gott im
bibel lesen
das ist eine andere aus sie finden aber
ich glaube sie verdient den gleichen
respekt ja respekt bin ich sehr an ihr
stand nur noch mal den hinweis auch von
frau cora schon mal die art wie wir
bibel lesen
ich nehme ein beispiel es gibt
zinsverbot es gibt verbot zu schwören
nennt niemanden euren vater als den
himmlischen ja es gibt es gibt die auf
forderungen deutscher nur alle sieben
jahre schuldenerlass zu machen ich habe
noch alle wunderbar ja ich habe noch nie
gehört dass mit gleicher vehemenz das
eingefordert wird
das ist das was die gemeinde bibel
zitieren vertrieb wurde noch
angesprochen von peter von sony ist das
einfach ein trick wenn sie zum beispiel
gleichgeschlechtliche paare segnen um
sie in der kirche zu halten
habe ich mir noch gar nicht überlegt
nein also ich sags noch mal ich bin
alles reformierte theologe jetzt weniger
an der tradition verpflichtet weniger
ich habe haben keine lehrmeinung die für
uns gilt aber ich bin den heiligen
schriften ich bin den biblischen
schriften verpflichtet und
selbstverständlich nehme ich sie in
ihrer auslegung der bibel ernst ich kann
ihnen einfach aus theologin sagen ich
finde sie fragwürdig das stimmt dass wir
genau ich weil ich einen sonst hätte ich
auch nicht sechs jahre studieren müssen
um einfach die bibel aufzuschlagen und
dann an zu streichen das passt mir und
das passt nämlich und das haben sie
jetzt gerade wichtig angesprochen oder
man kann die bibel nicht wörtlich lesen
man kann sie nicht selektiv lesen ich
kann nicht im buch articus anstreichen
wenn ein mann bei einem mann liegt wie
sie bei einer frau während meiner frau
liegt dann sind sie des todes und
daneben kleidung aus zwei
unterschiedlichen materialien sind sie
auch des todes dass es jetzt veraltet
dass andere gilt nicht so kann man mit
den biblischen texten nicht umgehen was
mir aber am meisten am herzen liegt ist
das evangelium von jesus christus und
hier finde ich wirklich kommen wir unter
umständen einen nicht ganz angenehmen
konflikt denn jesus sagt liebt einander
wie ich euch geliebt habe das ist
vorbehaltlose liebe einander die wir
einander entgegen bringen sollen das
höchste gebot neben der gottesliebe ist
die nächstenliebe und in der umsetzung
der ehe für alle das heißt dass wir
nicht mehr qualifizieren zwischen
wirklich verantwortungsvollen
liebesbeziehungen seien wir doch als
christin ohne testen froh dass ich
menschen dazu verpflichten wollen
verantwortungsvolle beziehungen
einzugehen das ist doch irrsinn als
christinnen und christen zu sagen nein
das wollen wir nicht das ist doch was
wir wollen
das ist doch was wir hochhalten wollen
die liebe zwischen den menschen die
verantwortungsvolle liebe die auch in
unserer gesellschaft strahlen soll und
deshalb finde ich dir für alle muss ein
grundsätzlich christliches anliegen sein
wenn man das evangelium von jesus
christus ernst gut galt trick
kein trick ich möchte gern einen schritt
weiter gehen bei der frage welche rechte
für gleichgeschlechtliche paare gehen in
einer ehe wenn es um die familienbildung
geht und wie das geht hat das fernsehen
ein dokumentarfilm gezeigt mit jerome
und patrick sie sind ein paar das dank
einer leihmutter in den usa sind die
beiden väter geworden von zwillingen wir
schauen uns kurz einen ausschnitt an wie
die beiden mit den zwillingsbabys nach
hause gekommen sind in die schweiz
[Applaus]
am 29
januar 2018 kommen jérome an patrick mit
klara und nathan in genf an
was empfanden sie in den ersten
augenblicken mit ihren babys liebe und
einem gefühl der erfüllung das gefühl
dass die familie jetzt komplett ist
das bewusstsein für sie da zu sein um
sie zu beschützen
und das ist fast wie ein versprechen das
wir ihnen gegeben haben als wir sie in
den arm nahmen
ich sagte ich werde für dich da sein
das hat mich auch sehr berührt verträgt
mit einem unserer kinder auf dem arm zu
sehen wie schwierig das andere hielt
lockere war ich war stolz dass wir es
geschafft haben und sehr gerührt große
rührung auch beim abschied von lindsay
die herzen waren schwer die tränen
flossen
das war von anfang an der moment vor dem
ich die größte angst hatte ich wusste
das würde sehr schwierig da hat es sonst
schon sehr geholfen zu wissen dass wir
sie in ein paar monaten wieder sehen
lege wert auf einladung des paares im
oktober anreisen um patrick herum und
die kinder die sie ausgetragen hat zu
sehen
es ist schwer unsere dankbarkeit in dem
maße zu zeigen wie wir das gerne tun
würden ich finde keine worte dafür
eigentlich hat sie unsere familie
möglich gemacht
[Musik]
ja was lösen die bilder bei hinaus v.li
ich bin immer gerührt wenn ich bei wie
sie auch nach 18 jahren noch aufheben
[Musik]
und sonst finde ich es einfach
ich finde es wunderbar wenn zwei
menschen die sich lieben auch familie
gründen
und was mir aber auch gerade wichtig ist
bei diesem punkt und zu unserem heutiger
zu unserer heutigen streitfrage in der
ehe für alle ist leihmutterschaft kein
thema wissenschaft nicht für mich das
ist frei mutterschaft in der schweiz ist
verboten ich möchte das möchte ich ganz
klar sagen dass das nicht zur diskussion
steht in dieser vorlag das war ja auch
in den usa dann nicht in der schweiz
wie beurteilen sie es denn in der runde
also dieser vorschlag der
rechtskommission des nationalrates
beinhaltet ganz klar die adoption von
kindern in de wenn sie denn kommt für
gleichgeschlechtliche paare
wie beurteilen sie das ich glaube es
steht noch nicht für diskussionen diese
vorlage bestimmt nicht der druck steigt
ab weil er uns familie sind auch
untrennbar irgendwo miteinander
verbunden darf ich das klären im
vorschlag der rechtskommission solang es
steht die aktion drin es steht in einem
bei gefühlten vorschlag die samenspende
drin als variante aber die adoption aus
dem vorschlag drin sein aber sie sehr
glücklich aber ich denke der druck
steigt weil zwei männer ja nicht ohne
eine frau ein kind bekommen können und
für mich fremd spenden und
leihmutterschaft die möchte ich auch für
heterosexuelle paare nicht aus sie nicht
dass wir die themen durcheinanderbringt
ich rede von adoption wie beurteilen sie
die automation von mir durch
gleichgeschlechtliche paare
ich glaube dass ein kind auf mutter und
vater entsteht und auch bei seinen
biologischen eltern leben
soll wo immer das möglich ist unfall
gegen geschlechtlichen eltern leben soll
einfach aus diesem entstehen heraus ich
glaube dass das sinn macht dass wir das
alle welt und das ist ja nicht mal bei
einer adoption heterosexuelles paar
genau aber ich denke auch da wo das
nicht möglich ist dass das kind bei
einem vater und bei einer mutter so
einfach sollte weil ich glaube dass das
für das kind ein förderndes gegenüber
eine fördernde spannung ist
ich weiß aber doch es zeigen bis zu 100
studien international inzwischen dass
kinder in regenbogenfamilien genauso
glücklich und gesund aufwachsen können
wie kinder in herkömmlichen familien
das finde ich etwas ganz ganz wichtiges
und wir leben ja auch in einer
gesellschaft wo so viele verschiedene
familienformen nach gibt es gibt der
patchworkfamilien es gibt eben die
herkömmliche familie es gibt ein eltern
familien und es gibt regenbogenfamilien
und ich finde das auch ganz wichtig dass
diese kinder eben auch geschützt sind
weil das sind sie heute nicht als sie
würden klar für das recht auf adoption
blättchen nicht nur das recht auf
adoption sondern auch diese zweite
variante die auch in die vernehmlassung
geht das recht auf den zugang zur
künstlichen befruchtung für lesbische
verheiratete paare und das argument dass
dort dann ungleich behandelt würden die
schwulen paar homosexuelles kann ich so
gar nicht nachvollziehen weil es ist die
rechtslage in der schweiz ist so dass
eben leihmutterschaft ist verboten und
es geht in dieser variante geht es darum
dass quasi das eigentlich dass
verheiratete lesbische frauen den
gleichen zugang zur verpflanzung medizin
haben wie heterosexuelle paare
darf ich noch mal zurück auf sie zu
also bei der frage der adoption
beeindruckt mich am meisten dass
menschen nicht nur auf sich bezogen sind
sondern sich auch öffnen verantwortung
zu übernehmen für ein kind das ist für
mich das beeindruckendste die frage die
sie dann als nächstes angesprochen dann
braucht es nicht vater und mutter also
das ist die leben ja nicht einem
atomisierten raum also das baby jetzt
mit zwei männern oder mit zwei frauen
sondern die sind ja auch eingebunden mit
freunden bekannten frauen und männern wo
eine vielfalt auch erlebbar wird
das einzige wo ich jetzt unsicher bin
ist was die alltäglichkeit angeht ja
aber ich kann mich erinnern dass ich mal
gelesen habe dass zum beispiel auch die
kinder heranwachsen kindergarten schule
auch mit anderen zusammen kommen und
ihre innere geschlechtliche biologische
identität leben können und nicht
deswegen weil sie bei zwei männern oder
zwei frauen aufwachsen automatisch
genauso die gleiche orientierung haben
was meinen sie mit alltäglichkeit ja in
der woche miteinander tag
das mache ich jetzt da sehen wir studien
klar die sie zitieren oder aber die
studien sind sehr jung das phänomen ist
nein das phänomen ist noch sehr jung
ich glaube um verlässliche aussagen zu
machen
die studien habe ich genau angeschaut
die kindheit zurück verlässt sie sind
wirklich so zahlreich und sie dann
wirklich zum schluss dass hier die
kinder keinen nachteil weder medizinisch
noch in ihrer entwicklung erleiden ich
würde gerne noch ein haken bei dem ein
kind braucht eine mutter und einen vater
war es selbstverständlich braucht es
eine biologische frau und einem
biologischen mann und ein dienstmädchen
zu zeugen wir sind jetzt aber bei der
adoption das heißt bei kindern die aus
irgendwelchen gründen nicht bei ihren
leiblichen eltern leben können
und wenn man dann sagt es braucht eine
biologische frau und einen biologischen
man um dieses kind großzuziehen weil nur
eine biologische frau mutter sein kann
und nur ein biologischer vater das
entspricht überhaupt nicht meine meine
männer und frauen meinem menschenbild
ich als biologische frau kann hoffen
ich genauso gut vater sein dh diese
eigenschaften haben die man einem vater
zuspricht wie mein mann mutter sein kann
dass diese eigenschaften in sich trägt
oder ausleben kann die man sonst einer
mutter zu spricht ich finde das ganz
schwierig zu sagen als biologische frau
muss ich die mütterlichen eigenschaften
haben und als biologischer man muss sich
die väterlichen eigenschaften haben das
führt mich auch dazu zum beispiel dass
es eine sehr große geringschätzung
meistens der männer ist es ist nicht
umsonst dass wir noch keine
vaterschaftsurlaub haben weil man den
männern noch viel zu wenig nützlich und
mütterliche eigenschaften zutraute und
wenn ich den sehr rührenden film dieser
zwei männer ich kann mir jetzt thema
leihmutterschaft aus aber diese große
liebe diese fürsorge dieser zwei männer
das ist doch mütterlich würden wir sagen
das sind denke ich erkennbar biologische
männer möchte aber jetzt noch beim das
sind interessante bilder mann/frau cg
jung animus anima was wir in uns tragen
welche bilder wir realisieren im alltag
habe ich möchte noch mal zurück auf
diesen zweiten vorschlag der
rechtskommission des nationalrates ist
eine variante ich betone dass mit
samenspende jetzt frage ich doch mal
wir hatten eine zeit da war es nicht
selbstverständlich dass katholiken
katholiken reformierte und umgekehrt
geheiratet haben also zwischen den
konfessionen
sie haben die eingetragene partnerschaft
heute wir stehen möglicherweise vor der
ehe für alle kommt dann die samenspende
kommt dann die öffnung wie sie sagen für
die fortpflanzungsmedizin kommt dann die
leihmutterschaft ist das hier
salamitaktik
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass der druck
darauf steigt wir sind im moment ganz
stark auch darauf ausgerichtet was
wünscht sich der einzelne stadt
vielleicht auch zu fragen was braucht
das ganze was braucht der staat ich
glaube dass dieser druck steigen wir
geben ich finde eben auch 40 jahre
studie nicht lange ich finde das nicht
eine lange zeit klar wir brauchen noch
mehr zeit um darüber nachzudenken und
ich persönlich
glaube nicht dass es für kinder gut ist
aus spenden spende dass die spende von
samenzellen einzeller zum beispiel
glaube ich nicht dass das der identität
des kindes förderlich ist die
kinderrechtskonvention sagt ja auch dass
kinder das recht haben bei ihren
geologischen eltern seines opfers wenn
es also bei ihnen nicht samenspender und
sie gesagt ja leihmutterschaft ist ja
konsens nein ich bin suchend besuchen
was ich denke wirklich dass ich für mich
ich habe so ein bisschen für mich ist
das problem ich möchte gerne die
fortpflanzungsmedizin wirklich trennen
von der frage für alle weil ich finde
hier wird auch ein bisschen eine
unheilbare allianz nach zum teil
taktisch gemacht weil man eben dann
diese szenarien und dann kommt das alles
und so ich finde es ist wichtig dass wir
über die zugang den zugang zur
fortpflanzungsmedizin sprechen aber
völlig unabhängig ob da jetzt den homo
oder hetero sexuellen paaren offen
stehen soll sondern einfach dieses thema
nehmen da bin ich beim thema
leihmutterschaft natürlich äußerst
kritisch auch aus feministischer sicht
kritisch
ich befürchte es könnte zu einer
ausbeutung der frau kommen zu einer
körperlichen ausbeutung der frau ist
könnte finanzielle druck geben auf auf
frauen gerade auch aus armen ländern ich
finde da braucht es ganz genaue
vorsichtsmaßnahmen wurde auch schon
diskutiert und landwirtschaft zum
beispiel nicht mehr bezahlt werden darf
oder dass dieses argument vom tisch ist
dass man sagt diese diesen menschen
lassen sie uns diese frauen lassen sich
kaufen ist ich finde es gibt gute gründe
die man gegen leihmutterschaft ins feld
führen kann respektive weil man sehr
kritisch sein muss das nicht zu einer
ausbeutung der frau kommt aber tatsache
ist ja dass wir eine ganz lange zeit
nicht darüber diskutiert haben dass das
jetzt plötzlich dieser konsens wie nicht
mehr da ist der ganz lange da war dass
es für heterosexuelle paare klar war
leihmutterschaft das ist gott das war
schweiz gar kein thema bis vor kurzem
nur schwangere ich rede mit dem zu was
vor gesagt hat das geht mir ähnlich
ich hab noch mal versucht vom kind her
zu denken
es wird irgendwann die frage kommen wo
ein kind wissen möchte wer ist meine
mutter wer ist mein vater und wie gehe
ich damit um dass das weiß ich jetzt
dabei das weiß ich jetzt
von von den nutzern zum thema
leihmutterschaft von männer paaren die
über leihmutter ein kind oder auch
zwillinge bekommen haben dass die den
kontakt dass es ihnen sehr wichtig ist
den kontakt weiter zu pflegen mit dieser
leim und dass das dass diese kinder also
haben wir an diesem beitrag auch gehört
dass die kinder wissen wer war diese
frau und die art uns ausgetragen
das wäre die positive variante vorrat
auf die andere aufmerksam gemacht die
mich einfach unsicher macht gedacht
haben gesagt schwanken
ich komme zu einer schlussrunde sie
merken wir kommen nach zum ende unseres
gesprächs wie beurteilen sie ist wenn
die ehe für alle kommt wie werden die
kirchen die kirche gemeinschaften die
christlichen gemeinschaften reagieren
ja man kann heute offen dann schauen wir
werden die christlichen gemeinschaften
reagieren
es wird es wird ganz viel diskussion
geben und ich hoffe ich hoffe aber auch
dass wir dass wir auch ins gespräch
miteinander gehen und das ist nicht
einfach diese zwei lager gibt von von
von menschen die er für alle von
vornherein ablehnen und solchen die aber
danach finden wie wir mit denen die das
ableben gar nicht reden
die reformierte kirche kirchen
reformierten landeskirche es gibt noch
sein dieser größte graben wo man weiß
die waadtländer kirch meine ich es dass
die noch ein bisschen kritischer
eingestellt auch intel sollte ja sonst
ist eigentlich konsens die ehe für alle
bringt die trauung für alle und trotzdem
möchte ich betonen wir haben theologisch
gesehen die trauben für alle schon
wir dürfen es nur nicht so nennen wir
sind also eigentlich auf kirche mal
vorreiterin
der kreis schließt sich zu ihren
eingangsworten wie wird die römisch
katholische kirche reagieren ich glaube
die irritation wird noch anhalten
ich hoffe aber auch dass die besinnung
auf gottes wort und die bereitschaft
gottes jedem den segen zuzusprechen
auch ein neues denken ermöglicht und
nach dem sägen könnte auch die heirat
kommen zum beispiel wenn sakrament heißt
es geht um einen beziehungs zeichen zwei
menschen drücken ausmachen zeichenhaft
sichtbar wie die liebe zueinander auch
noch mal die nähe gottes zum menschen
aus drückt also und fällt für viele ist
ja wichtig dass hier sagen wir möchten
das nicht als privat geschichte
wir möchten uns miteinander sehen lassen
und gesehen werden und wirklich auch
anerkannt sein dass hier geht's um
anerkennung wertschätzung durch auch
öffentliche institutionelle in ordnung
was denken sie die freikirchen
ich glaube freikirchen landeskirchen
werden sich darüber gedanken machen wie
man die persönliche freiheit der
pfarrerin der pfarrer gewährleisten kann
dass diese je nach ihren überzeugungen
handeln dürfen und ich glaube dass ich
diese kurz reformierte freiheit position
auch beziehen zu dürfen nach dem eigenen
gewissen zu handeln
und ich gehe davon aus dass das eine
diskussion sein wird wie gewährleisten
wir diese gewissensfreiheit könnte sein
dass die katholiken sich dann auf diese
gut reformatorische tradition berufen
und sagen wir machen hier nicht mit wir
werden es sehen ich bedanke mich
jedenfalls ganz herzlich für diese
diskussion hier mit ihnen ganz
herzlichen dank
eva cavalli herr block civil vor und
frau lehmann und am nebentisch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ganz herzlichen dank ihnen für ihr
interesse auch für den warmen applaus
hier geht es gleich weiter mit der
sternstunde philosophie und zwar mit dem
höchsten aller gefühle mit dem orgasmus
mit einem thema das bisher in der
philosophie offenbar noch wenig
beachtung gefunden hat
[Applaus]
[Musik]